locals will tell you that while snow is
in a common sight here we have several
winter storms over the past few years
some even bringing snow to the strip
this was the scene in 2019 some parts of
town seen about eight or nine
inches tonight we're waiting to see if
we get some more snow
madison kimbrough there tonight for more
on how people are taking to the change
hi madison
yes brian so it is certainly cold here
but no snow
or rain yet that doesn't mean it won't
come later but earlier it caused quite
the stir
around las vegas as people were excited
to see snow flurries in the air
and snow on the ground take a look at
the scene from earlier
in prim near the state line the 15 was
closed in both directions
eventually mid afternoon the roads
cleared up along i-15
and were open again here at the las
vegas sign the weather kept most people
away
but we did find one gentleman from out
of town not expecting these cooler
temperatures in the city
i was expecting it to be you know mid
60s to 70s maybe
but yeah definitely not snow and
freezing like chicago
and as ted's been saying more snow could
fall tonight we'll see what it looks
like
out here tomorrow morning and as we
mentioned before
the big snow or the last big snow was in
2019 and before that it was in 2009
and i'll tell you as someone who is new
to the area i didn't realize
it gets this cold all right reporting
live madison kimbrough 8
news now